よろしくお願いします
蛇の経典の途中で止まりましたけどね
パーリ文の百三十二の一番最後の行からと思います
アタコー バガヴァ ビクク
ワマンテーシ トゥンヘーピメー
ビクカウェー ワンダンマンデーシタン
アジャナータ ヤターマン
アリット ビクク ガッダバーディ
プッボ アッタナー ドゥッガヒテーナ
アムヘー チェワー バー
チッキャティ アッタナーチャ
カナティ バフンチャ プンヤン
パサヴァティヒティ でお釈迦様がこのアリッタさんのこの邪見を解くことはできなかったし
ですからあなたは自分勝手に頑張ってくださいということで
その人を無視して比丘たちに聞くんですね
あなた方も私はこういうふうな説法したことを覚えていますかと
どのような説法かというと
お釈迦様が修行に邪魔やと思ったものは
実は邪魔でないんだよとというふうな教えを教えたことが聞いたことがありましたと
こちらは一応欲のことを言ってるんですからね
性的な欲を満たすこととか
そういうものは悟りにはとんでもない障害であるというふうにお釈迦様もおっしゃってるんですね
それはそれなりの理由があって教えているんであって
それにもこの人は反対しているんですね
そこで比丘たちはそういうことはないんだと
私たちは別にアリッタの考え方を認めているわけではありませんと
ノーヘータン バンテ アネーカ
パリヤーエーナヒ ノー
バンテ アンタラーイカ
ダンマ ブッタ バガヴァ
世尊が障害になる危険なものについて
いろんな方法で説法なさいましたと
アランチャ パナテー パティセーヴァとアンテラーヤーヤ
そういう異性との関係を持っちゃうと
悟りはもう不可能になってしまいますよということで
アンテラーヤに危険に迷い
障害になるんだよと それでお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの例えがまたずっと出てきて
アッパッサーダー カーマー
ブッター バフドッカー
バフー パーヤーサ 欲っていうのはほんのわずかな喜びがあるんですけど
苦しみの方が多いし 悩みの方がより多いし
それからアーディーの方へ行って
ディーよ デメリットの方が多いんだと
メリットの方よりも アッティ
カンカ ルーパ マー カーマー
ブッター バガヴァ 骨に例えているんだと
欲というものは それからサッパ
シルーパ マー 蛇の頭に例えているんだと
そのように サーデュ ビクカウェー
サーデュ コーメー トゥンヘー
ビクカウェー エーワン
ダンマン デーシタン アジャナート
お釈迦様はそれを認めない
その大変いいことや良いことやと
サーデュっていうのは賛成で
そういう意味なんですね
よく仏教徒が使っている言葉で
あなた方はそのような理解をしているならば
それは大変ありがたいことだと言って
そのまま最後の方に行って
このアリッタが自分で誤解して仏教はわからなかった
この欲はなんで悟りに邪魔になるかというところは
もしかするとこの前の講義で説明したんだろうと思います
で 彼が自分で誤解してたくさん罪を犯しているだけでしょうと
彼にとっては長い間それは不幸の原因になるんだよと
ソーワタ ビクカウェー
アンニャトレーワ カーメーヒ
アンニャトラ カーマ サンニャーヤ
アンニャトラ カーマ ヴィタッケーヒ
カーメー パティセー ヴィッサンテーティ
ネータンターナン ヴィッジャティ
でお釈迦様がすぐにこの心理学的な状況を説明するんですね
欲に関する行為をするということがアンニャトレーワ
カーメーヒ 欲から離れて
だからお釈迦様が欲から離れた世界を教えているんだからね
物から離れる世界をね
欲から離れて欲的な行為をすることはできませんと
アンニャトラ カーマ サンニャーヤ
心の中で欲に関する思考
妄想いっぱいもうない場合は
全くない場合はもうそういう行動はしません
だからお釈迦様の立場っていうのは
欲っていうのは心の問題だと
心がおかしく回転すると欲が生まれるのであって
決して厳密に生物学的な
どうしても避けられない遺伝の刻まれているものですよとね
例えば食欲みたいにね
睡眠欲みたいに どうしても生命がしなくちゃいけないことなんですね
寝ないと脳には問題ないんだけど
体が疲れて壊れちゃうし
食べなかったら死んでしまっちゃうし
そういうものは体の構造の中でも一緒に編み込まれている欲求なんですね
では そのようなものではないんだと
この子孫を作る欲ということは
それは心の欲であるという立場なんですね
だからそれは現代的な
科学学問的な意見はどうかはわかりませんだけど
お釈迦様が言うのはほとんどいわゆる普通言えばメンタル的なものだと
性欲っていうのはね だから心が汚れて乱れているんだから
そんなことをほとんどこの非論理的にこの現象っていうのは実体として見るんだから
目に入る情報 耳に入る情報
頭の中でいろいろ幻覚化して
それできれいだ 美しいんだ
私のものにしたいんだとかね
頭の中で思うだけのことであって
体っていうのはそんなきれいなものでも美しいものでもないっていうのはね
お釈迦様の立場ですからね
で カーマサンニャ アンニャトラカーマヴィタッケヒ
欲に関する思考 まあヴィタルカっていうのは考えること
サンニャーっていうのは感情みたいに考えるたですね
まあそういう欲 欲の性的な欲のことを考えないで
カーマンパティセーヴェーティ
欲的な行為をするということはネータンターナンヴィッジェティ
ありえませんと ですから
お釈迦様にチャレンジしたい方々いるならば
まあどうぞいくらでも研究資料ありますからね
世の中で でお釈迦様おっしゃっていることは間違っているんだと
性欲っていうのは生物学的などうしても必要なものやと
という証拠あるんだったら
世界中の医学者たちと研究して話やってみて
やってみてください お釈迦様にとっては
それは単なる頭の問題ですね
イダ・ビッラヴェ・エーカッチ・モーガ・プリサ
まあそれからお釈迦様ポイント変えるんです
それから本当の経典始まります
イダ・ビッラヴェ・エーカッチ・モーガ・プリサ・ダンマン・パリアープナンテ
ある愚か者たちがダンマン・パリアープナンテ
法を学ぶ パリアープナンテっていうのは
よく勉強して理解して
まあ磨くということなんですね
ちょっと聞いて忘れるということじゃないんです
よく勉強して よく理解して
法について いわゆるよく研究して磨いて
知識人になるということなんですね
で パリアープナンテ そういう意味なんです
ちょっとまあ ちょっと聞きましたと
忘れちゃったとか それぐらいのことじゃないんです
とことん研究したりすることなんですね
それでもう専門家になっても
その人はモーガ・プリサ
もう愚か者やと ある愚か者たちがもう厳密に法を勉強するんだと
こちらでこの研究者が大変大事にするのは
この次のリストなんですよ
九つのリストが出てくるんですね
スッタン・ゲイヤン・ウェイヤーカラナン・ジャータカン
ウェイヤーカラナン・ガータン・ウダーナン・イティヴッタカン・ジャータカン・アブダダンマン・ウェーダッランという
それでお釈迦様は自分の説法について九つのカテゴリーを教えているんですね
だからお釈迦様が九つの種類の説法をしたんですよ
で それをお釈迦様の言葉で言ったことなんて
それはもうはっきりと全ての学者たちがお釈迦様が言った言葉として認めているんです
で 大乗経典になってくると
大乗経典は偉いんだから
それは十三にしているんですね
それでこの九つは 一番目はスッタというもの
二番目はゲイヤというもの
三番目ウェイヤーカラナン
四はガータ 五はウダーナン
六はイティヴッタカン
七はジャータカン 八はアブダダンマン
九番目はウェーダッランという
この言葉自体が古い言葉で
本当のところは意味はなかなか分かってないみたいんですね
で ただお釈迦様の教えをそのまままとめたんであって
まとめた人々はこの九つにまとめようとはしなかったんですね
ですから まとめたのはお釈迦様亡くなって三ヶ月間経っているのを第一月次でしたから
まあ大乗によると まあこれは何百年も経ってからということになりますけど
歴史を無視するのはまあそちらのことで
まあちゃんと歴史的に記録していますからね
まあそれはもう三ヶ月間経ったところで全部一応まとめたんですけど
まあ完成してこの名前をつけて終わったのは後かもしれませんですけどね
でも経典をまとめたその時はまあものすごく慌てて早くやったことですよ
おそらくね ですから この経典の長いものは長いものに
これは中だからね 中の長さ
中度の長さのものはそれに寝るたりとかね
短い教典はまとめようと思ったら
またやっぱり一冊でまとめられませんね
それでまあ項目ごとに一つをまとめてサンクタアガマと
で それで数字でもう一つまとめてみて
で 残りは全部まあ残りというふうにまとめてしまっちゃって
五つにまとめちゃったんですね
だからかなり焦っていたような気がするんですね
ですから この例えばこの冊にまとめているところにお釈迦様の一番古い
一番先におっしゃったものが入ってるんですよ
それから最後に後でお坊さんたち付け加えたものやらね
そういうものも入ってるんですね
だからこの時代 この経典研究してね
この配列作ろうと思ったら結構ややこしくなるんですね
そこで長部経典は一番目にしてるんですけど
では長部経典で全て古い経典だから
そうでもないんですね
ただ長さだけ考えちゃったんですね
だからそれは経典研究する学者たちにとっては
もうなかなかこの分からなくなっちゃって
何だろう 何だろうと いっちゃこっちゃ
むちゃくちゃいろんなこと言ってるんですよ
だから答え単純なんですよ
お坊さんたちが焦ってたんですよ
だからそんな真剣に研究したって意味がないんです
だからこんなにもうブッダ教徒らがすごい大事にこのパンチャアガマ
アゴンという まあその四つとも言うんだけど
パンチャとも言うんですけどね
四つか五つですね まあどちらでも五つですけど
で これは大変大事なもうまとめ方ではないかとかね
まあ大阿羅漢たちがなさったんだからということでね
もう真剣 そこはもう固定になってますからね
南伝でも北伝でも でもまあそれはまあそんなに厳密に
もう真剣に学問的に考えてっていうところじゃありません
だからまあただもうとにかく揃えましょうと
とにかく早く揃ってこれやと決めときましょうと
でなきゃ危険だと ということで
お釈迦様亡くなった途端
法の泉が消えちゃったんだから
もう流れてこないんだから
だから新しい車両も入らないんだよと
まあ大変だよと これ守らなくちゃということで
それだけにすごい必死になったと思いますね
だからもういろいろなんだかんだややこしいことではなくて
とにかくその方がまとめやすい
では長い経典 じゃあこれ
じゃあ長いものは一緒に
中のものを一緒にしましょうとか
というふうにね もう一応雑的にまとめて
まあそれからもうちょっと整理になった可能性ありますね
だから学者がこれ百年
百五十年経って経ったんだよとか
だから百五 お釈迦様亡くなって百五十年
二百年だよと できるだけ時代を遅らせちゃいたいんですね
できれば大乗よりも遅らせちゃいたいんだけど
それはちょっと無理だからね
そういう主観的でね 自分たちの好き勝手でもう研究するものだからね
まあ西洋研究はどうせこのもう邪教の研究という立場でやっていたんだからね
そちらで批判されるのはどうったことないんですけど
で それはそのままに受けて仏教研究をやっている仏教の人々も自分たちの好き勝手でもう研究やってしまったんだから
まあ結局仏教に対してはあんまりありがたいことではないとなってきちゃったんですね
それでもまあ随分最近の研究者たちがね
まあ日本ではいませんだけど
一人やっぱりその問題点をよく理解して
もう新しくもう全部考えなくてはいけないんだと
で 最近のもうみんなすごい一般学者たちが喋ってるものとやら
研究論文を読んでみるとね
すごくいいこと言ってて
まあ僕でもすごい小さい時は
これはおかしい これはこういう意味ではない
これはこういう意味ではないかと言ったところを
まあやっぱりそのままみんな言ってるんですね
当時で我々は馬鹿にされちゃったんですね
で 日本に来ても馬鹿にされちゃったんですけどね
間違ってるんだと で 正しいのはこの百五十年昔やった研究だそうですね
でも私はそんなめげるものではないんだからね
まあ今はもうそういうふうにやってますけど
あんまりパーリ仏教を勉強する
まあ今ないんですからね
場所も人気もないしね
まあですから お釈迦様の場合は
お釈迦様がこの九つに
私はその九つの種類の説法をしているんだよと
おっしゃったんだから
できればその九つにまとめた方がすごい良かったんじゃないかなと思いますけど
だからといって単純に大阿羅漢たちがミスを犯したかというとね
それはちょっとそうでもないんですね
その方々は我々よりもお釈迦様がスッタンゲイヤンウェイヤーガラナンというところはね
ガータンウダーナミティウッタガンウェーダル
ブッタダンマンウェーダルなんですね
そこはもう教えたことはもう僕らよりもちゃんと知ってるでしょうにね
もしかすると考えてみたかもしれません
そうするといろいろやっぱりちょっとややこしいんだよと
はっきりしないんだよというところでね
で 一番簡単な方法 経典は全部入る方法の枠組みを決めたかもしれません
だからかなり大きい枠組みを決めて
それに全部入れたっていうことは立派なことなんですよ
厳密に決めると 枠も決めちゃうと
その枠に入らないものが出てくるんですよ
それはどうしますかということも出てくるんだからね
だから この九つの意味はわかってないということもはっきりしているんです
それでも後で学者たちが厳密に研究して
これはこれで これはこれやっていう風に一応提示はしてあるんです
日本にあんまり知られてないんだから
そこら辺はちょっと秘密を置いておきます
一応論文とかはあります
ちゃんと九つの法門って何なのかっていうね
一番目スッタン スッタンっていうのはスッタですね
すべての経典名つけてる名前ですね
スッタンっていうのは
だから経典という意味なんですよ
では そういう意味ではないんですけど
で 一応かなりの量の研究はしているんです
それで結論だけ言います
日本では手に入らない
そういう研究論文とかはね
私も厳密に全部覚えてるわけではないんですけどね
スッタっていうのは このインドの一般的な
このある学問を語るときに使う一つの方法なんですよ
哲学やらね 哲学でもよろしいし
医学でもよろしい インドっていうのはものすごい学問の世界でしたから
学問的なものを語る場合は使う一つの方法で
あまり西洋思想ではないかもしれませんね
いくらか出てくるのは数学
西洋思想でいえば数学でいくらか出てくるんで
数式いっぱいありますね
物理学でも化学 化学でも全部ある方程式と何か数字でね
何かあの 何かこれっていう風に言っておいちゃうんですね
例えばあの人の相対論にしても
ほんの四つの数字でこれやと
イコールなんとかなんとかとかね
で 言ってしまっちゃうんですね
それがスッタなんですよ
そのスッタに至るためには
かなりの研究をしなくちゃいけないんですね
インドの場合は 厳密に論理的に何か語っている場合はスッタ形式で語る
だからスッタには本当の意味はこの糸という意味なんです
糸なんですね それでこのあの人の教えは何なのかと聞くと
そのスートラを語ればいいんです
この方程式を言えばいいんです
それで全部言ったことになるんで
それは本人も認める 本人が作った方程式だからね
だからその方程式を作って
本人が私はこういうことを語っているんだよとみんなに言うんですよ
そこでその人の思想は
その本人発表しているものでわかるんです
例えば現代的な研究とか何とかいうのも
最終的には結論出すんですね
だから結論を取って その学者はこの意見だよと言えばいいんです
まあこの論文はもう五冊六冊ぐらい大きいものかもしれませんけど
最終的には結論出しちゃうんですね
その結論 だから現代は結論は方程式では出さないんでしょうし
科学数学以外はね かなりもうぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ状態でね
いろいろ結論部分をね
完結するところ見ても
それでもはっきりしない
ぐちゃぐちゃってところよくあるんですよ
で 日本では結論全く出さないで
すっごい厚い論文を書いたりするんですね
ですから この文化系の論文などでは
このスッタ形式で結論は出てこませんが
この数学と科学系の場合はいつでも方程式で結論が出てくるんですね
ですから ちょっと A4の1ページぐらい
半分ぐらいででも膨大な研究っていうのがまとめられるので
これは誰かにわかるわけじゃないんだけど
それわかるためにはものすごいいろんな知識必要なんですけど
うん だからこのエネルギーの法則についてアインシュタインが書いた方程式っていうのはほとんどみんな覚えてるでしょうね
で だからといってそれでわかりますかって
また別な話で説明できますかというと
また別な話で でお釈迦様はそうやってこのもうインド文化に則って
もうお釈迦様もインドの学者でしたからね
まあ誰よりも大変もう頭も良かったし
ですからこのまあスッタ形式と言うんですよ
まあその形式で語ってるんです
そこでこの紀元六世紀でこのサンスクリット語の文法書を書かれちゃったんですね
で それをパーニニの文法書と言うんですけどね
すごい小さい本なんですよ
それを説明するためにはものすごい膨大になっちゃうんです
なぜ小さいか 全てスッタ形式で
それを暗記すればいいんで
暗記しておけば もうサンスクリット語では何一つ間違いなく書けるんです
それでパーニニは難しいということで
もうそれから学者の学生たちの勉強のためにサーラッサタというわかりな文法書があるんですよ
それは後で書かれたものですけど
もっとわかりやすい スットラもわかりやすい
で サーラッサタを勉強する人々も
そのスットラを全部覚えておく
覚えていて 先生のところでそのスットラはどんな意味でしょうかと
またずっと教えてもらう
教えてもらう分は覚えて簡単に覚えられるし
スットラは暗記しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで文法は間違わないってことになるんです
文法も一つの数学考え方で考えてるんだからね
言葉の文法も それで医学もだいたいそういう風になっていて
星占い学も占星術も結局はスットラ形式なんです
ですからまあしっかりしていますよ
だからこのインド知識系統っていうのは
このなんでみんなよく喋る
よく解釈できるという状態はそういうことなんですね
基本的なところはもうきちんと柱がもうしっかりもうついていますよ
それが解釈は自分の自由で解釈できるんです
いくらいろんな人がいろんな解釈をしても
柱は柱だからね それは変えることはできません
この内装はいくらやったっても
建物の基本的なところはもうどうにもならんだからね
で そういう風になってますね
だからお釈迦様は自分の経典はそうやって教えはスッタ形式で言いました
例えば生業無常であるとかね
それで終わり 完璧 それで我々はそれをずっと研究して研究して勉強すればいいんです
いくら自分の解釈をしても
生業無常であるということは変化することは絶対無理
それはもう禁止 それ書いちゃったら意味がないんだから
私は生業無常だと何を思うかと自分の思いは語れますよ
でも生業無常であるということを変えることはできません
だったら別な学問を語らなくちゃいけない
別な学問を語って 故に生業は無常ではありませんと言わなくちゃいけませんね
で 例えば怒りは怒りで収めるものではなくて
そうすると怒りが増えるだけです
怒りは慈しみで消えるものだよと
それは永遠の真理でしょうと
お釈迦様の一つの方程式なんですよ
ナヒ・ヴェーレナ・ヴェーラニ・サンマン・ティタ・プッジャッタナ
で ほとんど経典見てみると
そうやって全部決まり文句でピッタシともう出ているんです
その教え方がスッタなんです
だからジャユ教はスッタということではないんです
そちらにスッタという言葉を使ってしまっただけのことで
だからそこが まあそこまで言う必要あるかどうかわかりませんけど
とにかくまあわかりやすいところだけ言って終わりますけど
スッタっていうのはまあ生業無常とかね
まあ諸法無我であるとか
例えば生業無常と言って諸法無我と言うんでしょ
だから言葉もすごく気をつけているんです
で 涅槃と言えば もう貪瞋痴をなくした
滅尽したところが涅槃であるとかね
それから至福 最高な幸福とは涅槃でありとかね
そういうふうなこの言葉で決まって言うんですね
だから引用もしやすい
覚えやすい 他人にも言いやすい
それから意味はもう変化しません
解釈 たとえ変化しても
元の言葉はもういじることは不可能ですよ
それは柱だからね だから大乗にしたっても
全く仏教と脱却してまるっきり違う教えになってしまったんだけど
基本捨てることはできないんですよ
だから矛盾で終わって
もうすごいもうガタガタ言って捨てるわけにもいきませんし
でも自分の解釈と合わないしね
例えばもう神様がいて
すべてを創造して 我々は神様の分身だよと教え言ってますけど
それはそう言えば単純でわかりやすいのに
それは言えないんですね
神様は仏様に それ仏様言っちゃったらどうしようかと
ブッダが人間 人間ではなくて
発心だよとかね そういうふうにいろいろいろいろもう言葉のごまかしというかね
まあそういう話ね まあそれでお釈迦様がこのスッタをいっぱい教えましたと
で 歴史的に起きた問題は
このジャユ教やらね この前勉強したマールンカプッダ教とかね
そうやってこのあるお釈迦様の講演に
ある講義に マールンカに対して語った講義でしょうに
説法でしょうに だからまとめてまとめて説法に教というスッタという言葉を入れちゃったんだから
そこでちょっと問題が起きてしまっちゃったんですね
本当はそれはもう説法なんですよ
マールンカプッダ説法なんですけど
ジャユ教ではなくてジャユ説法なんですね
だからそこら辺で説法としないで
講義にしないでね スッタにしたんだから
ちょっとトラブっちゃったと思いますよ
まあそれはもう言語的なこともあります
例えば説法はダンマデーサナでしょうに
お釈迦様が 喋ることは全部ダンマデーサナにしているんだから
そこをちょっとできない
使うことできない あるいはデーサナだけにしちゃうともいいんですけどね
それはまあいいわ 学問的研究をするときは考えるべきなので
デーサナっていう で 二番目ゲイヤンなんですね
ゲイヤはもうこれまたインド文献によくあることで
そこでこのブッダゴーサ長老がこのスッタっていうのはウボト・ヴィバンガ・ニッデーサ・カンダカ・パリワラとか
この後ろの五番目書いてるあの中五番目書いてますね
それはブッダゴーサ長老の言ったことの日本語訳だけなんです
だからブッダゴーサ長老の訳は認めるかないかっていうのは
ウボト・ヴィバンガっていうのは比丘尼に対して書いてる戒律セットで
それはもう二百いくつかとかね
数字で決めてるんだからね
カンダカ・ニッデーサっていうのはアビダンマのテキストなんですけど
カンダカ・パリワラ全部戒律ですね
戒律の五本は五つの本はもうスッタにしているんですね
それで学者はそれおかしいやと
だってお釈迦様スッタ
ヴィナヤと別々にしているんですけど
お釈迦様も教え全てまとめてスッタにしているんです
でも戒律は別にヴィナヤにしているんですよ
だからヴィナヤとスッタが教えましたよと
ですからブッダゴーサ長老がスッタの中にヴィナヤ入れちゃうんですね
ヴィナヤっていうのは戒律だからね
そこでこのタカラ経とか
よくみんな暗記して覚える経典がありますね
ナーラカ・スッタやらトゥワタカ・スッタとかね
そういうものはスッタでしょうと
ほんのちょっとしか入れてないんですね
だからそれはまあちょっともうあやふやな分け方なんですね
ということは もうブッダゴーサ長老の時代になってくると
スッタって何なのかってもう分かっていなかったんですね
ブッダゴーサ長老のところがもうやっぱり昔ももうこうして
これは決めておかなかったんですね
これがスッタであると
でもよくもっと古い仏教より以前の文献から考えてみると
スッタっていうのは まあこの私はこの出ているいろんな研究のまとめを言ってますよ
それは方程式形式で倫理真理を語ることなんですね
ですから方程式で何か語ったら
必ずもう説明必要になっちゃうんです
でなきゃわからなくなっちゃうんです
マドビンディカ・スッタというこの前の経典に記されている
そこはもうある一つ方程式を出す
出したところでやっぱりわからない
このバラモン人に で 出て
お釈迦様 あのバラモン人にわからなかったよと
お釈迦様はわざとわからないように言ったんですけどね
それで弟子たちに言う
弟子たちはそうでございますかと
その話を聞いて自分たちもわからない
でお釈迦様に聞く お釈迦様はまたちょっと二回目の方程式を言うんですね
あれよりは長いんだけど
ちょっと軽いんだけど
それでもわからない それでそのお坊さんがまた他のお坊さんたちのところに行って
サールプット・ソンジャヤそういうところに行って
どうかこれを教えてくださいと言ったら
明確にわかりやすく解説してあげる
だから解説したっていうのは
結局最後に方程式を成立しておかないとよくないんですね
だからまあ全部まとめてスッタと言っちゃうとおかしいんですよ
ですから このマドビンディカ・スッタの場合でも
スッタが短いんですね
残りはそのスッタの解説なんです
そこでスッタニパータに出てくるものはほとんどスッタ形式なんです
ものすごい解釈が必要なんです
それが日本語訳されたんだから
なんだブッダの教え知ってるぞと思ったっても
どうかなと私は思いますけどね
その一つ一つのパーリの言葉にはものすごい意味が入っているんです
だから我々パーリ語で勉強する者は
一番手強いと思うのはスッタニパータなんです
できるだけ遠慮したいと
怖いんですね 触るのは難しすぎて
日本になってくる一番先にそれやってもということだからね
頭のいいこと じゃあそれはスッタでゲイヤっていうのはまたもう次二番目
もう一つ 教え方 文法 書き方で
ゲイヤの場合はこの言いたいことはまずプロス
文章で書いて それから詩に詩で書くんですね
この意味はこういう風にも言えますよと詩も書いてちゃうんです
だからこの文章と詩が散文と韻文と両方合わせて語るんですね
だからまず散文で言って
次に韻文が出る場合もあるし
韻文が出て散文が出てくる場合もあるし
混ぜて出てくる場合もあります
で 法華経なんかは一応その形をとっているんですね
で 散文があって韻文があると
だから単なる繰り返しじゃないんですけど
法華経だったら単なる繰り返しなんです
で なぜ散文と韻文で言うかというと
やっぱりそれなりにコミュニケーションする意味はやっぱり変わるんですよ
だから偈は偈の 詩は歌だからそれなりの意味持っているし
またコンパクトであってね
変えることはできないし
で 散文というのはプロスですか
散文の場合はやっぱりいろいろもう緩やかに書けるしね
で そういう風にその書き方なんですね
だからお釈迦様が説法するときも
その方法を使っていたんだと
もう書いたことはないんですけど
だからもうただその場で語るものだから
大変な能力が必要ですよ
今の人間にはもう絶対無理だと思いますよ
じゃあ即興ですぐさっさと言いたいことを歌にして語れますかね
みんな俳句とかね 書くでしょうに
もう瞬時にざらざらと何かについて俳句言えますかね
だから何のことなくわーっと言えるんだったら
まあ私はこういう こういうことを
こういう環境はこういう風に語りたいんだよと言って
一つ俳句を言うと そうするとゲイアになるんです
今日は皆様の状況やらもう顔を見たら
もうまあこういうなんとかスマで見たところで
まあ私はこういうことで
こういう風にこういう風なところで大変素晴らしいことではないかと
それで一つ こういう風に歌わせていただきますと
その同じことをすぐ瞬時に言えるならば
もうゲイアに上手な人にはなります
なかなかないと思いますけど
大変な難しいことなんです
筆で書く場合はいくらでも時間があるんだからね
書けますけどね それ 2番目
ヴェーヤーカラナっていうのは
このブッダゴーサ長老が
そこら辺はなんとかウッデホ長老も簡単にサッバンピサガータカンすったんゲイアンティ
全て偈が入っている経典はゲイアだよと
そういうふうに簡単にまとめちゃいますね
そうするとダブっちゃうんです
ダブっちゃうんですよ
だから分けられなかったんですね
レイヤーからの場合はサカランビアビダマビタカン
全てのアビダマがレイヤーからですよと
言ってもお釈迦様の時代ではアビダマというのはなかったしね
ニッガータカンすったん
ヤンチャアンニャンピアッテヒアンゲヒアサンガヒタンブッダワッチャナ
またある経典の名前を書いてニッガーハタカという経典と
他の八に入らない経典
全部ウェイヤーカラナだよと
まあそんなに 分け方ある？と聞きたくなりますけどね
でもヴェーヤーカルナっていうのは
この論理を 理論というか論理というかね
それはメインにして 方便として
それで語ることなんですね
だから一つの まあ説法終わったら
一つの論理語ったような感じになってしまっちゃうんですね
その教え方 それにいい例っていうのは
このマハ・ドゥッカッカンダ経典という
この中部経典に満つ経典があります
ドゥッカ 苦しみに対して書いている経典で
そこはもう厳密に論理でいくんです
純粋論理 純粋論理で だけど論理学ではないんです
論理を使用して真理を語る
だから私も同じ文化の人だから
私はあんまりこのここの章を使いませんだから
私はだいたいこのヴェーヤーカルナ形式と論理
まあすった形式なんですね
あれ喋ったものを一応書いてみて下さい
結構すった形式の言葉っていうのは結構出ると思います
で それにまた説明であって
それからすった形式の言葉が入る
それからもう時々厳密に論理形式で言って真理を語ると
その二つの方法を使ってますけど
で 自分の例で言うのは
お釈迦様に対して大変失礼なんですけど
皆さんにも分かりやすいと思いますけど
時々私はこのすった形式で
すべてのものは捨てるべきだよと
仏道は捨てる道だよと言うんですね
誰にも認めてくれませんけど
それはありがたい話ですからね
認めてくれないのは みんな知って同じくなっちゃったら困りますからね
だから私はずっと威張りますね
誰も自分のレベルに近寄ってないんだと
自分が偉いと だからまあありがたい話ですけど
一応捨てる道が仏道やってますよ
それはすった形式なんですよ
それで といっても大体まあだから何よっていうことになるのは当たり前ですよ
すった形式だからね それで説明する代わりには
それはゴミ論とかね 全部ゴミやと
ゴミだったら何をするんですかと
捨てるんでしょうに ゴミを大事にする人がいませんからね
で だからゴミとして認めなさいと
それでわからないと またまたいろいろ説明する
執着論が出てくると なぜ執着するんでしょうかというと
価値があるんだから これが大事やと思ったら我々大事にするでしょう
だから価値入れると執着が生まれる
だから論理的に物に価値入れるなよと
物に価値入れちゃうと
もうそちら側は執着 だから私は堂々と生きることはなんて素晴らしいと言ったら
もう腹が立って怒って喋るんですね
それで日本の文化うんぬんどうでもいいんです
私にとっては日本の文化うんぬんと言ったってもね
そんな価値がないんだからね
価値捨てるということだから
別に私は野蛮人で暴れ回ってるわけでも何でもないんです
逆かもしれませんだけど
こちらはもうきちんとこの何か言いたいことがあって
そこはもうバンバンと論理的に言ってもう壊してみるんですね
そこでこの なぜ我々にとって煩悩
執着があって捨てられないかというと
価値入れてるんですね
瞑想すると なんで妄想ばっかりするんでしょうかというと
これすごい価値入れてるんですね
家のことやら過去のことやら
いつでも思い浮かぶ 思い浮かぶと
もうすごく価値入れてるんです
それに気づかないんです
なんとかこの妄想消えてくれないかと
消えません 大事な妄想だから
宝物だから だから宝物やと思ってる間はね
これは消えませんし 解脱もなかなかね
もうニンジン ぶら下がってるニンジン論になるんです
いくら踏ん張っても もう一メートル先にあるんですね
だから価値入れるのはもうありがたいことに価値入れればとんでもないんですよ
例えば親がありがたいとか何とかったら
そんな単純な価値ですけど
自分が不幸にあったならば
親に捨てられたならば
それはよく覚えておいて
自分の人生まで不幸にする
だからその愚か者たちが知らないのは
親に捨てられたということが
自分がすっごく価値入れて
自分の人生哲学にしていることなんですよ
生きるための症状にしていることなんですよ
それで生きてるんですよ
その怒りで その憎しみで
だから忘れようと 昔話でしょうと
親に捨てられて次の日誰かに拾ってるんだから
その日から誰かにご飯食べさせて育てられたんだからね
どう計算したってもうまくいったということでしょうね
施設で育てられたっていうのは
もううまくいったと 親には捨てられたんだけど
施設で預かってもらって
もうちゃんと公お金でね
ちゃんと専門家に育てられたんだよと
本当は論理で考えれば万々歳状態なんですよ
一人寂しいで 親にいじめられながらね
頭の悪い母親にずっと十六歳八歳になるまではもういじめられていじめられてね
それでもう精神病気状態に陥るよりは
施設で専門家に見てもらって
育った方だともう宝くじ当たったようなもんなんですけど
でもその人々はまあそこはもう違う
非論理的に考えて それに価値入れちゃう
捨てられたことに価値入れちゃう
で みんなに親切してくれた日にちっていうのはあまりにも多いんですけど
親に三歳で捨てられても
それ一つの出来事だけなんですよ
1 日だけの不幸なんですよ
それから十八になるまで
もう守られて育ったでしょうに
その日にち数えてみれば
ですから 我々はこの妄想する時は
もう自分がこういうことになりました
こういうことになって
まあくだらないことを言うわ言うわ
すごい不幸な人生でしたとかね
それにすっごく価値入れてるんです
大事な宝物だと それに気づかないんですね
なんだ ゴミやではないかと
こんなゴミのことばっかり考えて
そんな昔 もう十二 三歳で
もう殴られ 親に殴られても
今もうどうったことないでしょうに
今さら親も死んでるってではないかと
でも そういう風にはもう気楽に考えられないんですね
そこで文化っていうのは
もう食べ物を拝む あれ何なのかと随分価値入れてる
拝んで食べる 目上の人には手を合わせませんね
何か教えてあげる人に全然手を合わせません
私ちょくちょくチェックしますけどね
ご挨拶はこうやって ご挨拶のある人もいます
まあそれはもう慣れだったから
しょうがない 別に私は気にしませんだけど
そういう参詣する時でも
ご挨拶もこうやっていう人も何か食い物あげたらもう拝むんですね
別にお釈迦様に手を合わせなくたって別にどうったことはないんだけど
それなりの知識人でインテリで
我々私たちの生き方やというならば
そうじゃあいいよということで全然気にしませんだけどね
だからそういう人間っていうのは
いろいろ価値の世界作って作って生きていて
絶対執着を捨てられない状態になっているんですね
それで私は論理的にそれ説明する
論理はあなたは買い物に行く
スーパーに行く それでいろんないろんな買い物をする
するとレジでそれはビニール袋に入れてくれる
ビニール袋っていうのはどうせゴミでしょ
ゴミは早く処分した方がいいんですよ
いいことに スーパーだったら大体はもう分別してゴミ捨てるようになってるんです
あのプラスチックトレーはこちらですよと
発泡スチロール系はこちらです
ビニールはこちらですよと
ビンはこちらですよと
スチール缶がこちらでアルミ缶がこちら
ちゃんと だからゴミ捨てるんだったらもう絶好なところなんです
外よりも 例えば生協とかね
もうきちんともう牛乳パックまで捨てられますね
でも納豆のパックだけは持ってこないでくださいと
それはまあ捨ててくださいってだけ書いてますけどね
牛乳パックも全部ちゃんと洗って干して
まあ持ってきてと まあそれは自然を守るために一生懸命やってることで
まあ大変ありがたいことで
でもゴミを家まで持っていって
またそれを分けて また生協まで持って帰るっていうことはね
面倒くさいでしょうに
だから なんでそのスーパーでもらったこのビニール袋
そのまま外でそのゴミ箱に捨てて品物だけ持っていかないんですかね
なんででしょうかね 価値があるんですよ
このビニール袋を ないと家まで品物持っていけないんですよ
じゃあキャベツ買って
あるいはキュウリ買って
まあヨーグルトも買って
もう魚も買ったら どうやって持っていけるんですかね
だからビニール袋に入れて持っていくんです
ビニール袋に価値があるんですよ
捨てません 持っていく時でも
これ破れないようにと気をつける
自転車で向こうから来る自転車にぶつかっちゃって
これ破れちゃいますからね
そうすると品物全部落ちますからね
気をつけるんです 大事にする
価値があるんだから そこで品物を家に持ってきて
まあ冷蔵庫やらそれなりに入れた瞬間であのビニール袋はどうなるんです？それはもうゴミ
もう価値がないんですね
それで価値が消えたところでゴミにするんです
それでも価値を入れる人はいます
これまた使えますよと
また使えますよと思う人は
またそれを丁寧に畳んで大事に置いておく
価値入れてるんです 価値を入れてない人は
まあそのままゴミに捨てちゃうと
だから執着捨てるためには価値を捨てない限りは無理なんです
日本の文化を守ると私に頼んでも
これは非仏教的なんです
邪教的な思想なんです
それ価値入れることでしょうに
この存在の三界の存在
梵天 神々 人間 全部まとめてわずかな価値も入れませんよというの仏陀の言葉なんです
たとえわずかな価値もあるんだったら
あんた方に解脱しなさいと言いませんよと
だからなぜ解脱できない
なぜヴィパッサナー進めないかというと
ただそれだけのことで
すっごいもう宝物を守っている
それで私が助けてあげたければ
私はあんた方の宝物っていうのはゴミだと
臭いんだと言わなくちゃいけないんです
で 腹が立ったってもしょうがないんです
腹が立つということ自体は
あまりにも執着あるということなんですね
それで喧嘩しながらでも理解していくと
無執着の世界に成長はできるんですよ
だから執着捨てるということは
すった形式で なぜ執着するんでしょうかというのは論理形式で
ヴェーヤーカラナ形式なんですね
だいたいっていうのは
説法っていうのはその二つのスタイルでいくんです
ゲイヤはまあ無理ですね
まあスリランカでゲイヤで説法するお坊さんたちもいますけど
まああれは私はもうインチキやと思ってます
みんなもう自分でもう詩はすっと作るんです
何かお釈迦様の説法を何かに中心にして
もうたくさんもう詩を作って
それを暗記して で 綺麗な声で
まあみんなもう声はいいんですよ
そういう人々が すごい綺麗な声で
まあもう詩を歌って それの説明をちょっとして
またいくつか詩を歌ってとか
それで綺麗な声で もう詩を歌うのを聞きたいんだから
もういっぱい大勢の人々が集めて
今日はまあこういう説法やと
もう誰もゲイヤっていうことを知りませんから
まあ別な言葉使いますけどね
今日はゲイヤ形式で説法ありますから
みんなで聞きましょうということで行っちゃいますけどね
それで才能ある人々は
その場でその場で即興的に作っていう時もありますけど
それはものすごく人気が出ます
すぐその場でも言いますからね
そういう能力ある人もいますけどね
でもその場合は単なる詩人になるだけで
中身がなくなっちゃうんですね
ただ言葉の遊びする それをブッダが否定しているんですね
言葉の遊びするなよと
そこでゲイヤっていうのはそういう形式なの
とにかく ヴェーヤーカラナっていうのは論理的に説法を語ることなんですね
ですから よく質問が出て答えが出る
質問が出て答えが出ると
だから経典読むと いつでもお釈迦様は質問して答え出す
質問して答えを出す それも一つのヴェーヤーカルナの形式なんですね
だからまあ応答なんですけど
やっぱり少々分析して
論理的に だから私に出せる質問したって
はい そうですねと 終わらないでしょうに
全部もう徹底的に分析する
だからそこはヴェーヤーカルナの形式なんですね
だから普通の人々をやっている
このもうなんかちょっと質問形式でダイアログ形式で本書きましょうと
そういう単純なことじゃないんです
次 何でしたっけ ヴェーヤーカルナ
ガータン ガータンというのは純粋に偈ですね
で スッタニパータナ ほとんど偈ですね
ダンマパダもほとんど偈ですね
ウダーナなんていうのは喜びを表す言葉だと
環境という意味なんですね
ですから この内容もありますけど
やっぱりもうやっと悟りましたよという風なね
なんかこの明るいんですね
勝利宣言みたいな 例えばこの因果法則の最後でアネーカ・ジャーティ・サンサーラン
サンダーヴィッサ・アニッティサン
あれはウダーナなんです
ですから ウダーナは偈でもよろしいし
散文でもよろしいんですね
例えば お釈迦様 キーナー・ジャーティ・カタン・カルニーヤン・ブシタン・ブラフマチャリアンというでしょ
生は終わりました なすべきことはなし終えた
修行は終えた もうこれからやることないぞと
こう喜んで言うんですよ
それは散文ですね アネーカ・ジャーティ・サンサーランというのは韻文で偈ですね
私はこの無始なる輪廻転生してね
もうずっと彷徨って生きて彷徨っていたんだと
もう回数知らんほど もう輪廻転生しながらしながら迷っていたんだよと
サンダーヴィッサ 迷っていたんだよと
アニッティサン もうどうにもなんの解決法も見つからなかったと
それでガハ・カーラカ・ディッティヨシ
この建物を作る大工見つかりましたと
建物というのは体のこと
なぜ再生するかなぜ輪廻転生するかと
これ体ができちゃうでしょうに
この大工さん見つかりましたと
このカッサヤ因縁 ウナギ・エハナカ
もう二度とあんたはもうこの体作れませんよと
大工さんが捕まりましたから
捕まったんだから また家を建てませんと
だからその場合は家に例えていて
それだから偈でもあって
ウダーナでもありますね
サッバーテ・パースガッバー
あんたの梁は全部壊しちゃったと
ガハ・コータン この梁を全部つなげる真ん中のあれももう壊したと
もう何もないんだと 材料は
ヴィサンカーラ・ガタン・チッタン
心にはもうすべての現象が心から消えてしまったと
サンカーラが エネルギーが
タンナー・ナンカヤ・マッジャガ
カッサヤよ もうなくなってしまったと
で お釈迦様の喜びを表して悟りを表してるんであって
ちゃんとした仏教なんですと
ちゃんとした教えはあります
あるんだけど 同時に明るくて
もうやったぞという勝利宣言ですね
そういう風な この悟った喜びを混ぜて喋るところは
ウダーナになるんですね
だからウダーナは別にまとめてテキストにはなってます
ウダーナというテキスト
ウダーナの次 イティヴッタカン
イティヴッタカンも一つテキストなんですね
こちらで勉強会で終わるまでやりましたからね
だからもう本当はウダーナはまとめていたんですよ
イティヴッタカンもまとめていたんですね
で スッタゲイヤなんですってね
問題になったのは だからイティヴッタカンの意味は
このように言われましたというふうなことで
だからこういうふうに言えるんだよと
いわゆる説明をして だから私はこういうことを言うんだよと
だから賢者がこういうふうに言うんだよと
という形式なんですね
イティヴッタカンは だからイティヴッタカンの場合は
まず説明が出てきて 最後に結論が出てくる形式にはなります
逆にすることも簡単ですけど
なぜこういうふうに賢者に言われましたと
こういうふうに賢者に言われますよと
なぜでしょうかと また説明することもできます
形式になっちゃうんです
なんとなく引用するスタイルですね
何々さんがこう言ってますよと
なぜそういうふうに言うんでしょうかと
お釈迦様はあまり他人に引用していないんですけど
もうたまに引用するんですけどね
昔は 古の人はこう言いましたとかはね
言いますけどね あまり引用してないんですけどね
それでジャータカ ジャータカもまたジャータカテキストあるんですね
それもすごく古いんです
物語はもう本当にそれお釈迦様の先祖物語かっていうことはもうちょっとわからないんですけど
でもジャータカ文献自体は仏教には欠かせない文献なんです
経典で言えないもの 全部ジャータカスタイルで言うんですね
だからジャータカにある偈は
韻文はものすごい古い
だから経典で通して残っているのは韻文だけ
この今我々が読んで楽しがっているストーリーは注釈なんです
後で注釈 後でできたんだから
あっちこっちからストーリーね
いろんな文献から拾い集めることできるでしょ
だからもういろいろインドのストーリーやらね
もありまして ジャータカからイソップに入ったストーリーもあるしね
ですから まあそんなに確実にお釈迦様の先祖物語でなくてもいいんですね
やっぱりこの物語形式で真理を語る
それもインド文化の一つなんですね
ヒトーパデーサという作品があるんで
サンスクリット語で その作品はもうすごい立派な作品で
ある王様にこのもうどうにもならない出来の悪い息子たちがいたんですよ
もう出来が悪い 頭も悪い
それで 父親はものすごく心配してたんですよ
この子供たちは勉強はしない
でも私が死んじゃったら国を治めなくちゃいけない
大変なことになるんだと
他の国に囚われて この子供たちが殺される可能性もあるし
父親は心配して あるすごい頭のいい先生を頼んだんですね
頼んで 私の息子はものすごい頭が悪いんだと
でも育ててほしいんだと
一人前の王子として あんたにできますかと
この人 まあ任せてくださいと
任せてください 私が教えてみせますよと
全て世の中の生き方やら法律やら
政治家としての道やら
政治学 法律 私教える 道徳
その三つですから 一番大事なのは
私教えてあげますよと
一番難しい科目なんですよ
政治学と法律と道徳っていうのは
言って この人は子供たちがすぐまんま別に勉強ではなくて
まあちょっと物語言いますよと言って
おとぎ話を一つ言ったんですね
そのおとぎ話を終わると
この王子たちが一人前の知識人になって終わったんです
だからヒトーパデーサっていうのは
もうほとんどサンスクリットを勉強する学者たちが
学生さんがよく勉強する本の一つなんですと
結構大きいんですけど
すごい立派ですよ ものすごい可愛いバカバカらしい物語も出てきて
次から次へ次から次へと出てくるんです
そこで興味を一本にするために特別そうな工夫をしているんです
それがこのメインストーリーが始まるんですよ
もうライオンがいて もうもうジャッカルがいて
そこでライオンの王様ってそういう風な話なんですよ
それでその中からサブストーリーズというこの枝分かれ
枝分かれ 枝分かれ 枝分かれ
そこでジャッケルが誰かに会った時は
その人はもうこういう物語って
そこでその物語にまた中にまた物語が出てきて
また他の物語がそうやってものすごく枝分かれるんですよ
だから小さな小さなエピソードいっぱいあります
一つ一つエピソードで
一つのポイントはぎっしりと教えているんです
そこで韻文も一つ入っているんです
それは何のことなく覚えられちゃう
それを覚えてないとストーリーは誰かに面白おかしく語れないんです
そこで勉強終わっていると
子供たちがちゃんと韻文は覚えているし
道徳を学んでいる 判決はどうするべきかと
友達って誰なのかと 友達を裏切るということはどういうことかと
王っていうのはどんなもので
王は王にいろんな噂言って
王をこのとんでもないね
もう腐った悪王にする方法やら
そこはどのように気をつければいいかとか
ストーリーからストーリー
ストーリーからストーリーで
だからこの大量に学問するよりは
1個のストーリーで全部教えてあげることができるんですね
ですから この物語という時話っていうのはものすごい大事なことなんです
そこはこのアラビアの物語とかね
ものすごい汚くしていますけど
例えばイーソップ物語っていうのは一つ一つ大事なことを言ってるでしょうに
イーソップの欠点というのはつなげてないんですね
ヒトプデサとテキストの場合は
ヒトプデサにもイーソップに入ったストーリーあるんだけど
全部 1本につなげてる
1本につなげて 枝分かれて分かれて分かれて分かれてネットワークになって
最後に前のストーリーが最後にもうバンバンサイで終了するんです
そこで卒業になるんですね
この子供たちに ですから
ジャータカスタイルというのは
そういう大変な素晴らしい説法の仕方なんですね
アッブタダンマンというのは
お釈迦様はアッブタダンマン
アッブタダンマンという言葉使ってね
もう言ってるし これはこの一つ
この不可思議なものということで
常識とはちょっと違いますよとという話なんですね
ウェーダッランはなかなかまだわからないんですよ
で 経典ではチュッラウェーダラ
マハーウェーダラという経典
ブトッス ブテーキテー
サッマディティス サッカパンジャスッタ
サンカーラバージャニーヤ
マハアプンナマスッタアデヨ
ブッダガス長老いうのは
この理解することとすごく喜ぶ
納得して その 2つ組み合わせた話し方がね
みんな喜ばせながら この喋ると
例えば何か難しいポイントを理解してもらいたくて
なんとかちょっとふざけた冗談なんか一つ言うとかね
みんなその冗談で内容を覚えておくというね
そうするともう話もよく楽しかったとかね
よく勉強になりましたという
その風な教え方だと でも北米になってくるとウェーダラワイプルジャっていう風になってますから
あれは哲学 純粋哲学になってますね
すごくこのもう何と言いますか
硬い純粋哲学というふうにもなっているみたいですね
だからどんな意味で取るかっていうと
ちょっとわからない 我々は大乗仏教はウェートゥルヤ
ワイトゥルヤワーダというんですね
このワイトゥルヤっていうのはサンスクリットの発音で
これパーリ語になるとウェートゥルヤになるんですけど
結局ヴェーダルラのおなまりですけど
だから大乗はヴェーダルラにしているんだから
大乗っていうのは屁理屈ばっかり言ってるんだから
それはもう日本で知られてる大乗じゃなくて
この初期時代の大乗なんですね
だから初期時代の人々は
大乗 大乗だと別にこのすごいバカにされる言葉を使っていなかったんですね
後で誰か誰かが使ってたみたいですけどね
自分たちは自分たちの哲学で名前を知られて欲しかったんです
それでワイトゥルヤという言葉を使ってましたけどね
ワイトゥルヤというサンスクリット語は
やっぱりショーニャ 空論に当てはめるんだという研究発表はあるんですね
それは研究した坊さんが死んじゃったんだけど
ですから この研究してみると純粋哲学のようなことになります
仏教道理に合わせちゃうと
聞いて楽しくて勉強になりましたという形式の経典だよと
それで九つの教え方ですね
だからその九つで経典の内容というよりも
お釈迦様の説法の仕方
いかに頭のいい能力のある人でしたかというね
もう単なるこの神の言葉をしゃべるとかね
霊言を語るとかね そんな精神な病気じゃないんです
で すごくこの表現はどのように表現すればいいかと
この内容はこういうふうに表現すればいいんじゃないかとかね
そういうこの説法の方法とかね
そういうところまで考えて
お釈迦様はお話をしているんだと
だからお釈迦様は内容だけではなくて
このスタイルまでものすごく気をつけてるんですよ
語るスタイルにせざるを得ない
その中でもかなりの能力の人でないと語れない
例えば詩だけで語るんだと言ったら
大変な難しいことで ゲイア形式で語るんだったら
ものすごい難しいんですよ
いきなりウェイヤーからの形式になっちゃうと
ものすごく厳密に哲学者の感じで論理的に言わなくちゃいけないし
スッタ形式になっちゃうとまたすごいやり方でしょうにね
その九つ テータンダンマンパリアプニトワ
テーサンダンマーナンパンニャーヤアッタンナウパパリッカンティ
テー 彼らがタンダンマン
この法をパリアプニトワ
勉強はするんだけど テーサンダンマーナン
そのダンマの法のアッタン
意味をパンニャーヤ 知恵で
ウパパリッカンティ 知恵でもって観察しようとしない
いわゆる中身の意味を理解しようとしない
ただ勉強だけする テーサンテーダンマパンニャーヤアッタンアヌパパリッカタムニッジャーナンカマティ
ニッジャーナンカマティっていうのは納得いくことなんですね
で なんて読みでしょうかね
生業無常ということはとかね
それを真剣に考察しようとはしない
ブッダは生業無常と言ったんですね
それで終わっちゃうんですね
それで まあ生業 生業っていうのはサンカーラですね
それはサンカーラで サンスクリットでサンスカーラって言うんですよ
ティベット語でまた何とか言うですよと
ドイツ語はこういう訳
そんな簡単に終わっちゃうんです
自分でどんな意味でしょうかとはもう理解しようとしない
ですから 納得は 本人では納得いかないんです
ニッジャーナンカマティ
だから自分で納得いかないんだから
テーウパーランバーニサンサー
ウパーランバーっていうのは喧嘩することですね
ウパーランバーニサンサーっていうのは
まあ非難することをメリットにして
だから誰を非難するかということになる
ブッダの教えというのはすごい巨大な
ものすごい強い教えだから
それを覚えておけば もうむちゃくちゃ他人の教えを非難することはできます
人をバカにすることはとても簡単にできます
そんなお釈迦様 それは狙っているわけじゃないんです
だからそこは仏教の危険なところなんですよ
我々はこの無執着の教えを教えるために
人間の執着をけなしてるだけなんです
人をバカにするために言ってるわけじゃないんです
例えば無価値論でもよく勉強すれば
随分好き勝手で この世の中で暴れ馬のように生活できますよ
何でもバカにしちゃって
そういうけしからんない生き方をするために教えてるわけじゃないんです
心にある執着を捨てるために仏教では非価値論を語っているんであって
私は自分の言葉でゴミとかなんとか使っているのは
我々の心にあるこの執着
それは捨ててほしいんだからであって
私がもうあんな教えなんかゴミだよと言ったら
あんた知ってますかね
スマナサーラが言うんだから
あんたの教えはゴミだよと
それもその人を非難することであって
そんな人を馬鹿にしてとんでもない行儀の悪いもう犯罪に当たることは仏教は語りません
そういうことは犯罪ですから
そこら辺すごい微妙で
気をつけなくちゃいけないところなんです
お釈迦様はその危険性をよくわかっていて
すごく厳しく論争するために使うなよと
次の言葉はイティワーダパモッカーヤ
イティっていうのは これでワーダ
論争から私はうまく勝ちますよと
論争 自分に論争をかけちゃったら
これで言ってもう脱出しますよと
だからブッダの論理を使って相手と論争をかけちゃったところで勝ってしまう
モッカーっていうのは解脱ですから
脱出ですからね 論争に勝ちますよと
この法で論争に勝ちますよと
論争に勝てますよと 論争に勝てるためにはいいポイント見つけたぞというぐらいの話なんです
そのために仏教を勉強するんだと
ヤッサチャアッタヤダンマンパリアープナンティタンチャッサアッタンナーヌボーダンティ
ヤッサチャアッタヤ お釈迦様は何かの目的があって説法しているんですよ
解脱の目的だから そのために喋っているんであって
人を馬鹿にするために喋っているわけじゃないんです
人と喧嘩するために喋っているわけじゃないんです
自分の心を清らかにするために
こういうものすごいことを言っているんであって
それでもって じゃあこれでもって喧嘩しようとかね
とんでもないことになっちゃうんですね
だからお釈迦様は何か目的があって
非価値論やら無常論やら語っているんでしょうし
目的は解脱なんですね
その目的に達することは全くないんだけど
タンチャッサアッタンナーヌボーダンティ
解脱することもできなくなる
テーサンテーダンマドゥッガヒータディーガラッタンアヒタイドゥッカヤサンワッタンダ
そこで彼らがそうやって間違って法を勉強すると
頭良くなるために 学者になるために
みんなによりすっごい頭いいと
頭いいと褒めてもらうために
あるいはありとあらゆる世の中の文化やら価値観やら宗教やら哲学やら
それをこの頃に壊すために
そんな目的で仏教を勉強するということはとんでもない間違いと
壊せるのは当たり前かもしれませんだけど
そのためにやっているわけじゃないんです
その人々には長い間苦しみになっちゃうんだと
だって社会からも非難されるし
それでドゥッガヒータッタビッケーダンマーナ
法を間違って取るなよと
間違ったらとんでもないことになるんだと
それからその経典の題になっている例えが出てきます
セイヤタイビッケープリソーアラガッダッティコアラガッダガヴェーシーアラガッダパリーエサナンチャラマーノ
繰り返し文句で百三十三の下なんですね
下から五行目 セイヤタービビッケイプリソウアラガッダッティコ
アラガッダっていうのはヘビ
ヘビが欲しくて アラガッダガヴェーシ
ヘビを探してるんですね
アラガッダパリエサナンチャラマノ
ヘビ探しに出ていく ヘビが欲しくて
ヘビを探して ヘビ探しに出ていくと
もう繰り返し文句で ソウパッスイエマハンタンアラガッダ
すごいバカでかいヘビを見つかるんだと
タメーナンボーゲーワナングッテーワガンヘイエ
ヘビを見つけたらすぐ体で取る
あるいは尻尾の方で捕まってみると
タッサソウアラガッドパティパリワッティットワ
そうするとヘビがどうしますか？とパティパリワッティットワって後ろに回ってきて
ハッテーワバハーエワアンニャタラスミンワアングパッチャンゲラセイエ
ヘビがそうやって立ち上がってきて
自分の手か体のどこかもう噛むんですよ
すごい大きなヘビが見つけて
尻尾のところで逃げてるんだから
じゃあ尻尾で捕まえそうと
あるいは体の方で捕まった途端
ヘビが回ってきて自分を刺すでしょうに
ソウタトーニダーナンマラナンワーニガッチエイエ
ヘビに噛まれたら そのタトーニダーナン
その原因でマラナンワーニガッチエイエ
死ぬんですよと マラナマッタンワードゥッカ
あるいは死ぬぐらいの苦しみに遭うんだよと
タンキッスってなぜでしょうか
ドゥッガヒータビッケイアラガッダッサ
ヘビを間違って捕まったんだから
間違ったところを捕まったんだから殺されますよと
だから法も解脱の目的で勉強するんであって
人と喧嘩するために勉強しちゃうと自分が地獄に落ちるんだよと
ブッダを侮辱することになるんです
ブッダがこの世の中一番優しい人で
誰も非難したことはないし
敵でもブッダと喋ったらすぐ味方になったでしょうし
ブッダには敵がいませんでした
ブッダを殺そうとしたんだけど
だいぶだったらそれは敵ではなくて
親戚争いで でもそれでもできなかったし
その人でも最後にやっぱりお釈迦様が偉いと
お釈迦様しか私の苦しみをなくしてくれる人がいないと
結局最後にまたブッダに帰依したんですからね
お釈迦様を殺すために応援したアジャセ王がね
仏教の歴史上で一番信仰深い信者さんとして褒められているんです
あの人ほど信仰深い人はいないんだと
それぐらいブッダの味方になったんだからね
ですから ブッダには敵はいなかったし
ブラマン人の教えは批判したんだけど
ブラマン人がブッダこそ我々のことを心配してくれるんだよと
だから そんな立派な方の教えをね
人をバカにするために
人を非難するために 自分が威張るために
俺が知ってるぞと そんなために勉強しちゃうと
もう自分が地獄に落ちるんだよというふうな厳しい
ヘビを尻尾か体の方で捕まったことと同じですよと
そのようにある愚か者たちが真面目に勉強はするんだけど
そういうふうに悪いことになってしまっちゃうんだと
そこでまた逆の言葉が出てきて
またセイエットイダパナビッケイエーカッチェクルプッタダンマンパリヤプナーティスッタングエッヤンウィッヤカラナンと出てきて
タンテータンダンマンパリヤプニットワテーサンダンマーナンパンニャーヤアッタングウパリッカンティ
お釈迦様の教えを聞いて
ものすごい頭を使って
このどんな意味でしょうか
どんな意味でしょうか
どんな意味でしょうかと理解する
例えば私はゴミ論を出しちゃうと
なんで変な話ばっかしと
それその反応だけでしょうに
もうちょっと考えたら
我々は持っている建物であろうか
もう他の宝石類であろうか
カバンであろうか やっぱりゴミだと言ってるんでしょうとかね
で なんで価値があるんでしょうかって
そこら辺もちょっと研究してみたらいかがでしょうかね
そうすると すごい違う次元で物事を見えるようになるんです
たとえシャネルのカバンであろうか
全く同じ品質で もっといい材料で
例えばインド人が作ったら買うんですかね
同じもの すごい素晴らしい品質で
すごいデザインで作ったら買いますかね
買わないでしょうに そこでフランスのどこかの店から買ったら
これはもう本物で そういうところで買ったぞと
そういうことになるだけのことじゃない
そこで価値がどこにあるんでしょうかと
そこでメーカー知られていないカバンだったら
これはちょっとあまり良くないね
ちょっと大きすぎとか
いちいち文句言うでしょうね
もうシャネルのカバンがありますよ
単なる買い物バスケットみたいに
バカでかくて もう持っていけないし
もうカッコ悪いし ものすごい威張って持っていくんですよ
透明なバッグもあるでしょ
透明なバッグで化粧道具とか入りますかね
どれぐらいもう立派な頭というと
この ああいうこの買い物バスケットみたいに
ものすごい大きなあれを買ったら
この家にあるお風呂にある鏡入ります
それぐらいバカでかい鏡を入れちゃって
女の子たちがね 電車でこうやって鏡持って出てお化粧する
今普通の女の子だったらね
今まではね ちょっと小さなね
鏡で見てお化粧直しするでしょうし
それでカバンに合うようなね
大きなお風呂につけたっても
お風呂にもちょっと大きいすぎだなというぐらいの
それもすごい究極的な価値でしょ
借金して あるいは体まででも売って買ってるものでしょうに
そこ価値の世界なんですよ
だからそれはバカにするんではなくて
あんたバカやっていう
そういう方向に行っちゃうんですよ
あなたバカやっていうところに行くんじゃなくて
子供たちは勝手に遊べばいいでしょうに
別に 私そんなこと言ったって別にまあもう何の苦しい苦もないんだからね
もう遊んでいればいいんじゃないかと
遊ぶのはそのうちだよと
それから地獄は待っているんだから
死ぬまでどうってことないし
だから私も年だからね
やっぱり本当のところ遊んでほしいんですよ
だからといって その価値の無知な世界を認めているわけじゃないんです
私も自分の子で 若者なんかもう失踪でいると
もう怒って怒鳴って 強引に連れて行って
いろいろおしゃれもの
おしゃれ道具とか買ってあげたりまでするんです
やっぱりやるのは かっこよく見せているのはその年だけであって
誰から見ても若い子は可愛いし
だから汚いだらしないふうにするなよとかね
髪の毛がちょっとでもおかしくなったら
すごく怒って なんだこの髪の毛とかちゃんと整理しなさいとかね
それでも興味ないんだったら強引に連れて行くんです
床屋に こいつ捕まって持っていけと
言って もう強引にでもカットしてもらって
いくらかもうかっこよくさせてあげますよ
だからといって 別にそういう見えの世界を評価してれば
それは別の話で それは心の問題であって
だから ああいう風なもうかっこ悪いサングラスありますよ
このもう顔いっぱい鼻まで来るぐらい
でもシャネルだからね
このフレームはもう 3センチぐらいあります
だからそちらに価値がどこにあるかと考えてみる
そうすると妄想にある
見栄にあると それも心の問題であって
自分の見方の問題であって
それで妄想すれば もうどんなもう犬のフンでも価値になるでしょうと
天皇陛下飼っているペットの犬がそこら辺で糞をしたんだと思ったら
天皇陛下犬の散歩をしているとする
それで天皇陛下神様やと価値が入れている人がいるならば
あの糞を持っていって
家で大変大事に保管するでしょうに
価値っていうのはそんなもんなんですよ
一般人に会うことできないんだからそんなことはないんですけど
タイだったらやっぱりあります
タイの王は時々一般の人々とも会ったり話したりしますからね
タイ人にとっては王はもうブッダと同じ
ものすごい神なんですね
一般人に会うのは仏教行事ある時だけですけど
お寺に来ますからね その時は王の足に踏まれた
もう何かもうもうハンカチでもみんな捨てるみたいに
もうそうやっていろいろなものを
で 王が歩いていくんだからね
みんなグルーって 王に踏まれちゃったら
まあもうこれほどありがたいことはなくて
って持っていって 大事に拝もうと
だからそちらにもうまあ妄想
人の人間でしょうし 他の人間と何の違いもないんですけど
そこでなんで価値が入るかというと
思考 妄想 サンニャーでしょうに
だからルイヴィトンが立派やとかね
シャネルが立派やとか
エルメスが立派やとかね
というのは同じことであって
それで我々食べ物にしても同じことでも食べて美味しいっていうことではなくて
付加価値で評価価値で妄想価値の方で生きてるんですよ
どんな食べ物でも食べたらそれから臭いものになるんであって
調理法はフランスであろうか
中国式であろうか 日本式であろうか
もう鶏は鶏だから 遺体は遺体だから
これでもう腐ってる死んでる死体を食べてるんだけど
それに入れる価値なんかはどんなものでしょうかね
それで何が増えるかというと
自分にはすごい執着増える
煩悩が増える それに自分を合わせなくちゃいけない
それで自分を死んでしまっちゃう
それでストレスも溜まる
恥もかける 人を侮辱したり貶したりもする
フランス料理を食べると
相手が道具の使い方わからなかったら
まあなんだ あんな変な人やとかね
だから食べるために行くんじゃないんですよ
人を侮辱するために行ってるんだから
フランス人は平気で手で持って食べるんだけど
それでフランス人でない人々はフランス料理を食べると
もう学校に行って習っていくんですよ
ポケットに書いてるんですね
メモ フランス人はカニてもカニ手で取ってもうやっって食べるんですよ
別に 骨がついてると もう何のことなく骨で取って食べて骨捨てちゃうんです
手を洗うんです それだけのことですけど
先に食べてますけど ですから
やっぱりそういう風に我々はもうものすごい価値の世界を作っちゃって
ダイヤは運とかね ルビーはなんとかとかね
それでも死に苦しみ 苦しみで生きている
死ぬ時も死ねない 自分のダイヤはあのお嫁さんに取られたらどうしようかとかね
これ家の宝物やとかね
それお化けになって またダイヤの乗り移るとかね
だから死んでも天国にも行けなくなっちゃう
だからそういうふうなことだから
それは人をバカにするために使う教えじゃないんですよ
それは頭でその意味を吟味して理解して
心の安らぎを味わうために
苦しみをなくすために仰っているものなんですね
ですから この次に出てくるのは
そういうパンニャーアッタンルッパバリッカティ
その人は知恵でもって
そういうふうによく理解する
よく観察する 観察するとウパバリッカタンニッジャーナンカマンティ
納得いく あ なるほど そういうことでしたと
よく納得いく テーナチェーバウパールンバーニサンサダンマンパリヤプナンティ
人を批判するために勉強することはしません
そんなこと自体もう汚い怒りで見えですからね
ナイティワードパモッカーニサンサン
論争して勝とうと思って勉強することではありません
それで 法を何のために教えたかという
その目的にも達するんだと
理由はスッガヒタービットウェダンマーナン
正しく捕まったんだから
教えを それでまた同じく蛇の例えが出てきて
蛇欲しい人がいて 蛇を探しに行く
巨大な蛇を見つかる タメナンアジャパデーナダンデーナスニッガヒータンニッガヘイア
そのこの番目の人はアジャパデーナダンデーナ
アジャパダっていうのは山羊の足って意味なんですよ
山羊の足は2つに割れてますね
だから棒を1本持ってくるんですよ
長い棒 そこで最後のところは2つに枝切っちゃえばね
こうなってる枝をこうやって切って棒を取っちゃえば
もう分けてますからね
そういうアジャパダダンダというね
棒を持っていてスニッガヒータンニッガヘイア
この場合はニッガヘイっていうのは非難する意味なんですけど
この場合はもう治める
抑えるということで よくヘビをじっと押さえておく
アジャパダダンってこんな風だから
こうやってきちんと押さえておく
棒ですからね ヘビがもう上がってきたってもさせませんしね
遠くへヘビだから 例えば頭の方が捕まなくても
もう体の方でもいいんだから
あのあれでこうやってY型になっているあれで押さえればヘビが逃げられませんから
それでキンチャーピソービキアアラガッドタッサプリサッサハッタンワーバーハンワー
アンニャタランワーアンガパッチャンワーボーゲヒパリウェーテイエアタコーソーネーヴァタトーニダーナンマラナンワーニガッチェーマラナマッタンワーデュッカン
それでだいたいアジャパダでっていうのは
だいたい頭の方ですけどね
頭の方をちゃんと押さえておけば
ヘビが自分の体を上げて
もう攻撃しますよ 逃げたくて
そこでその人の足を巻こうか
手に巻こうがもう関係ないやと
死にませんと 噛まれませんだから
向こうはもう噛む部分はもう押さえているんだからね
頭でもう押さえているんだから
だから今でもインドでもどこでもヘビを捕まえる人は頭で首で取っちゃうでしょうね
ヘビを首のところら辺でこうやって取っちゃえば
何のことない ヘビがもうグルグルグルグルと回ったり
回って舞えたり いろんなことするんだけど
噛めませんだから それで
その段落の最後のところ
タスマーティヘ ビックウェ ヤッサメー バハティサス アッタン アージャネイヤータ タターナン ダーレイヤータ
タスマーティヘ ビックウェ
ですから比丘らよ ヤッサメー バハティサス アッタン アージャネイヤータ
私が教えたことの意味をそのように覚えておいてくださいと
余計な解釈とかいろんなことしないで
そのように覚えておいてください
ヤッサジャパナメー バハティサス アッタン アージャネイヤータ
もしあなた方 私が仰ったことの意味がわからないならば
アハンゴ タッタ パティプッチタッボ
私に質問しなさいよと
私が何か喋ったら分かったならば
その意味その通りに理解してください
もし分からなかったならば
逆に私に質問してください
イエワ パナッス ヴィヤッタ ビックー
あるいは本当に頭の良いもう勉強している他のお坊さんに質問してみてくださいと
というところで このヘビの例えはそういうこと
だからお釈迦様は法をヘビに毒蛇に例えているんです
頭で捕まえてくださいと
いい加減で中途半端で取っちゃうと死ぬんだそうと
だからもう簡単ではないんですよ
仏教を語ることというのは
もう大変な革命的で ものすごいもう怖いものなんですね
ですから もうもうすごいその意味をわかって
これを解脱のために 心の煩悩をなくすために教えるんだと
人をバカにするためではない
だから人間いうことは何一つの真理ではないんだから
どうせもう批判されますけど
それは人を批判しているんではなくて
無知をなくして智慧の世界に来てくださいという意味なんです
で そこら辺で終了いたします
[紙の音]